so step number one for voiding the
collapse of civilization is try not to
COFF on one another okay so so this is a
virus and disease epidemics caused by
microbes like this viruses and also
bacteria these are the things that
precipitated the fall of the Roman
Empire and of the Golden Age of Athens
and of most of the empires of the Native
Americans and it's sort of surprising
that when you look at the largest threat
to the survival of civilizations it's
something so small and in fact it's so
invisibly small that viruses and
bacteria weren't understood until very
recently in history and yet despite
their their small size these have caused
more death and destruction than all the
famines and Wars put together so take
take as an example smallpox which is
which was the most destructive disease
in history it's killed hundreds of
millions of people between ancient times
and 1977 when it was finally eradicated
the Romans lost up to 1/3 of their
population and parts of their empire and
about a millennium later what happened
is the Crusaders came back from
pillaging distant lands and they brought
an epidemic of smallpox to Europe
Europeans then went over to the new
world they brought smallpox to the new
world and and in doing so devastated the
the Incas and the Mayans and other
natives there and some of you may know
in 1707 smallpox wiped out a third of
Iceland so similarly the the Black
Plague you're sending a pestis this
wiped out a third of Europe starting in
1347 and then it kept coming back to
haunt Europe century after century
yellow fever so badly decimated
Napoleon's armies in Haiti that Napoleon
gave up the idea of having a Western
French Empire just because of yellow
fever because of his 22,000 crack
soldiers that he'd sent to Haiti 21,000
them died and and so he gave up and
that's why Napoleon sold the Louisiana
territory to the United States because
he finally he said
I just don't want to be running this
show can confronting diseases that I no
longer understand so he he sold it for
roughly five cents an acre which in a
bloodless man manner doubled the size of
the United States okay and so it goes on
and on there are there are these viruses
and bacteria that have really navigated
the course of history in major ways and
what I'm going to suggest is that the
Internet is really our key to survival
here and this is for three reasons first
what the internet gives us is the
ability to work remotely and when you
can work from home tell it presently
what this allows you to do is is inhibit
viral transmission by reducing
face-to-face contact the human human
contact so in in the face so here's the
idea
the next time that there is a really
killer virus coming our way if
businesses are prepared in advance what
they can do is really leverage
telepresence to keep supply chains
running with the maximum number of
employees working from home now this
isn't going to keep everybody off the
street but it's going to vastly reduce
the density and it turns out that when
it comes to epidemics that's all you
need to do you just need to get things
below a tipping point so the reason
viruses have this sort of tipping point
is because viruses have a limited
lifetime and a certain probability of
infecting somebody and so if you have
very low hosts density then the virus
dies before it can get to a new host but
as soon as you get enough people
together then it can find new hosts and
you go from some sort of equilibrium
state into an epidemic it really blows
up and in fact you can see this sort of
thing happening every Christmas holiday
season with people shopping in the malls
because they all bunched together and
then you cross over this population
tipping point then everyone gets flu and
cold okay so now here's the problem in
the past societies have reacted to
epidemics by bunching together so for
example in medieval Europe when the
Black Plague hit and other plagues like
it warring religious factions who spent
all their time killing each other would
would show
solidarity in the face of all this death
by marching together in the streets
together to show that the Catholics and
the Protestants could be friends in the
face of the plague well that was a real
misstep in terms of density and it turns
out that the Native Americans in a show
of goodwill they would gather in the
tents of people who were infected with
smallpox that everyone would gather
together and again unfortunate that was
a gesture that was sort of ill-fated and
so this is exactly the fear that all
major medical centers have the next time
we have a major a new strain hitting us
whether it's avian flu or swine flu or
something the big fear that medical
centers have is that everybody with a
cough is gonna come flocking into the
Med Center to get checked out and this
is really dangerous and so I think this
is the second great opportunity afforded
to us by the net besides telepresence is
is telemedicine whereby with
increasingly sophisticated technologies
we don't have to have base patients
coming in and bunching up together but
instead we can have diagnosis from a
distance okay so the telepresence and
the telemedicine are very useful because
they keep the population density below a
tipping point I think there's a third
benefit that we get from the internet
which is we can optimally direct
resources when there is an outbreak so
you may know that the Center for Disease
Control tracks the flu by tracking what
happens at the local hospitals now the
thing is it takes two weeks for the CDC
to put together their report it lags the
actual flu outbreak by two weeks so
Google came up with a better idea and
what they do is they track where people
are searching for terms related to the
flu so if they're searching for the
information on symptoms or medicines or
something it turns out that over the
course of the nation that serves as an
excellent proxy for where there's a flu
outbreak so while the CDC's report lags
by two weeks Google's lags by only a day
so this gives us a very rapid way to
know dynamically exactly where the flu
is and where the outbreaks are happening
okay so unlike previous generations that
were brought down
by disease especially because they
didn't know how to react in terms of
density and sparseness we can now do
better because of the Internet if we're
well prepared when the next epidemic
arrives we can fluidly shift into a self
quarantine telepresence society in which
the microbes fail by dint of hosts
sparseness and so there's a lot of talk
of course about the ills of social
isolation and everybody's sitting on
Facebook but whatever those ills are it
bodes a lot worse for the microbes than
it does for us so although we're well
into this step there's there's work to
be done if we want to save our
civilization businesses really need to
work on developing their disaster plans
and and and their work from home
epidemic plans I wrote a paper on this
in the journal Nature about five years
ago and I've been watching as businesses
have been doing this I've been
monitoring sort of how this is going
some businesses are doing it most aren't
still it's really important to try to
get businesses to do this and it's
extremely easy to test right to work out
the kinks by having everybody work from
home and then the second thing as a
society we really need to keep
developing telemedicine and similar
ideas like that
[Music]